commonsense for your dollars and since
this is the Dave Ramsey show we teach
you to live on less than you make a
concept Congress can't grasp we teach
you to save money in the house of the
wise or stores of choice food and oil
but a foolish man devours all he has if
you spend everything you make you're a
fool on a plan live on a plan a budget
jesus said don't build a tower without
first counting the cost lest you get
halfway up and you're unable to finish
and all who see you begin to mock you
and say this man began to build and was
unable to finish we teach you to stay
out of debt because the rich rules over
the poor and the borrower is slave some
of you feeling that right now slave to
the lender we teach you to be
outrageously generous God loves a
cheerful Giver
and we teach you to hang out with people
who you want to be like be not deceived
evil company corrupts good habits you
become who you hang around with we teach
you these common-sense God's and
grandmas principles and here's the
beauty of these principles they work
when things are going really good when
the economy is white-hot and everybody
has a job and there's no worries and
skittles and rainbows everywhere they
work you can become very very prosperous
using those principles these principles
also work when there's a coronavirus and
everybody's preoccupied and scared to
death and can't breathe and terrified
then they kind of lost their minds a
little bit some of them a lot hysteria
is in the land and people are losing
their jobs left and right these
principles work then too because if
you're out of debt and you have an
emergency fund and you're investing that
works in good times and you have a plan
and you're generous that works in good
times and that works in bad times it's
the only set of financial principles
that work all the time they're not
situational because your values that you
use the principles that you use to run
your life and handle your
money will be tested when stupid shows
up and when stupid tres stress tests
your ideas you get to find out if your
ideas were crap or not and you got to
decide what are you gonna base your life
on you're gonna base your finances your
marriage your kids your career your
peace of mind I wear some stress out
there right now I got a little around
here there's stress around the
difference is where's your piece come
from I know where my stress comes from
but where's the peace come from and is
it bigger is the source richer and is it
deeper the peace that passes
understanding through Christ Jesus
there's a piece that's got some depth to
it that's a real one
that's not Pollyanna it's not to say
that I won't have stress I've had stress
as 24 hours it's freakin unbelievable
last week I got the rare opportunity to
cancel a sold-out cruise now that was a
joyful freakin moment so yeah we get
stressed but the question is are we
going to be overwhelmed by it owned by
it is the world going to come unraveled
inside of our brain what are you basing
your life on what's your foundation the
principles that we teach work in great
times and they work in bad times and
they're the only set of principles that
do and I didn't invent them I stole them
from God your grandmother I just have
been the best marketer of them in the
last century to convince people to do
this and when people have done this I'm
it's all over social media today do
rimsey all those Dave Ramsey people are
happy they got their emergency fund and
Dave Ramsey emergency fund people and
yeah well shut up it's a nice place to
be when there's an emergent you know hey
I'm the guy been selling umbrellas and
it's raining you know I'm popular right
now so there you go so all the sudden I
looked like a dad-blame genius but I was
a genius all along because I stole it
all from God your grandmother I didn't
in any of it never was really a genius
I'm just really good at talking about it
and making people believe they can do it
and getting them to go do it and it
changes everything when you do that's
where you are right now that's where you
are right now so if you're really scared
right now and things are really tough
and some stuff piled up on you hey I've
been there understand you're gonna be
okay
you're gonna get there you're fretting
and worrying about the virus you're
gonna be okay you're gonna be okay
something's gonna kill all of us you
don't get out of this alive so whatever
you know I just die sometimes you get to
choose what it is sometimes you don't
but something's gonna kill all of us so
really I mean I'm not gonna sit around
and go you know all these people down at
car wrecks so I'm walking wait a minute
pedestrians get hit too so now what do I
do so I'm now I'm screwed up you know I
mean as soon as you try to alleviate all
these things that are you can't do it
you can't do it you got to find your
peace in something other than a false
cocoon living in a bubble you can't do
it it won't work for you
so embrace this life embrace it smile
and step into it and yeah sometimes the
scariest credd understand and sometimes
you don't know how the lights are gonna
be kept on it sometimes you're worried
about how we're gonna do this but listen
you're gonna be okay
you're gonna be okay keep your wits
about you stay calm you're gonna be okay
you're gonna be fine it may get a little
rough I've been there I'm not saying
it's gonna be perfect but you know when
we get to this time next year you're all
gonna still be laughing about the toilet
paper it's gonna be the great toilet
paper rush of the spring of 2020 that's
what people are gonna remember it's
gonna be a it's gonna be a memory it's
gonna be a thing some of you can't tell
me about y2k some of you can't tell me
about 2008 some of you can't tell me
about the swine flu almost none of you
can tell me about polio but all of these
things we're going to bring the world to
an end at one point if you don't
remember
and people were overdramatizing them and
hysterical about them and scared to
death and there was no peace in the land
because there's always something that
will come and challenge your little
values and if your little values aren't
based on the rock they're gonna crumble
they're sinking sand
you're gonna have a problem and this is
the time you're stress tested and the
horrible news is you're stress tested
the great news is you get to determine
what's real it's gonna show up it's
gonna go that doesn't work that does
work I'm never gonna be here again I'm
gonna have the emergency fund I'm gonna
be out of debt I don't have any payments
anywhere would that be different in this
situation for most people yes I mean I
can't I can't sell it for groceries or
toilet paper but I'm sitting in a
seventy million dollar paid for building
that's a pretty cool place to be when
there's a storm outside I feel like the
little pig in the brick house not the
one in the straw house when the big bad
wolf came in he often he puffed and he
blew your house down you know but I was
in the straw house before and I went
this straw house thing ain't working man
I'm out of here
next time the big bad wolf comes around
we're gonna be in the brick house cube
brick house from disco days but anyway
Yeah right
so I mean really Wow so not bragging and
I'm not shaming and I'm not
condescending I'm right there with you I
understand but there's something for
everyone out there right now in these
unique moments and you get to discover
in these unique moments who you is or
you get to decide who you is maybe you
didn't like who you is and now's your
time to change you can make a decision
to decide you just decide I'm not never
again man when we hit bottom I said so
many times never again never again while
I do business with American Express
never again under any circumstances
freakin thieves meant liars cheats
scoundrels never again will I do
business with Fifth Third Bank liars
cheats scoundrels I mean you get these
opportunities we just go I've learned my
lesson I'm not reaching my hand back in
there Bert
my fingers no thank you you get to
decide there's something in this for
everyone something in this for everyone
and I'm here to help you find